today we're going to just start by
talking about what glass is and what its
properties are
um and uh but before we do uh
this came in you know we've been talking
about defects okay
and what vacancies
point defects and then and then on
wednesday we did line defects remember
those
right and and they create these these
planes that come in they're slip planes
that
allow atoms to slide across each other
that allows you to plastically deform a
material
uh and so okay but with with regards to
vacancies i got this
in in by email i'm at the heathrow
airport in london
and even this aerial sculpture has
vacancy point defects in its pattern
look at that there you go and there you
go
this is a beautiful thing right thank
you sophia
um this uh and notice that she's looking
at it with her periodic table
of course right uh that that's a
no-brainer
um but even even such structures can't
escape the fact that you always have
vacancies
that was cool okay now where were we
right so um
we're going to talk about glass now this
is glass and i
i'll start with just how cool glass is
but this is also
not just this isn't all that glass is
and i want to make sure we get that by
the end of this lecture this is not the
only thing
that glass means but this is what we
think of so here's a really cool video
oh okay no
and they're there look at that molten
table and back away oh he's added
something we'll talk about that
oh and that is mixing it table man
carefully mixes his glass to the two
problems work
okay there it is is it a liquid he picks
that up into the solid
and he feeds it between two rollers and
then he just puts it through
and pins it together a little roller
smash that glass flat
smash it flat and there's your piece of
glass
okay and we'll see another one i'll show
you another video of a
larger scale don't don't keep going
okay so what was it that they were just
mixing
why does it have the properties that it
has
why can they just kind of take this
thing that's not really liquid and not
really
solid it's some viscous thing and and
roll it through and then it comes into
this really beautiful
sheet that we all call glass
and it all has to do with what what
i showed you before and what we've been
talking about which is order
or disorder okay and and so we did this
already we covered
uh okay solid as a dimensionally stable
that's cool uh classification oh
ordered regular long-range order
bcc fcc
right okay long range remember we said
it just keeps going
and going and going and then we say well
maybe once in a while once every
thousand ten thousand a hundred thousand
there's a vacancy okay so we started
messing with it but it still had this
long-range gazentine order
and so they were called crystalline
crystalline with defects maybe but still
crystalline
that is not what glass is glass
is disordered and so that is the topic
of today and next
wednesday what happens when you go from
an ordered structure like this or maybe
it's got some
some oh these are 2d defects right two
whole things are kind of so it's
polycrystalline but it's still kind of
crystalline it's very order
to totally disordered right
and so a disordered solid
looks random certainly over long range
there might be short range order there
might be some short range order but over
a long range
it's going to be disordered it's going
to look random
this is called amorphous as opposed to
crystalline
this is also called glass
this is also called glass so one of the
first things we have yeah
this is really important glass is not
just the window or the thing on your
phone that keeps cracking
no glass
is equal to an amorphous solid
and well you know it's so it's bigger
it's broader
it's bolder you can have glass metal
metallic glass it's a thing
any solid that doesn't have long range
order that's amorphous
is a glass okay now
in this class uh uh we will use
sio2 as so what we're going to do
is we're going to talk about glass with
an example
we will use the kind that winds up being
on the windshield in the windshield of
your car
in the window of your house and on your
phone and that is called quartz
so the chemistry that we're going to use
is quartz
or sio2 okay
and what we're going to talk about is
how processing
affects that chemistry affects the sorry
the solid
that forms so processing and there's
lots of processing
parameters we could talk about what i
want to focus on today
is the cooling the cooling rate in
particular
so that's going to be the focus today
we'll talk about the chemistry
we'll talk about the processing and
we'll talk about how those go back and
forth
to create glass
now okay what am i starting with i'm
starting
with a crystal this is quartz
this is how you see now quartz is this
beautiful
beautiful crystal and it is ordered
that's why i'm saying the word crystal
i'm not saying the word glass all right
this is an
ordered solid it's not cubic so it's not
one of the ones we've learned
but it's still periodically repeating
right and and so it's a crystal it's got
long-range order it's called quartz
it's it's sio2 so i'm going to hand this
out
so you can just see it and that's what i
want to start i want to talk about
is that crystal okay because that's
what we're going to be messing up
and creating short range we're going to
go from
long range to short range okay so what
is it well let's see
now we think in this class how do we
think about chemistry
well we can we can think about it now in
different ways let's pick
lewis all right okay so
i said okay i've got silicon silicon
silicon if i think about silicon as its
lewis
uh you know dots then it's got four
it's got four uh valence electrons ready
to bond
well you you can see that now if i have
oxygen
what does oxygen look okay so oxygen has
has six i'm going to put those like that
so oxygen has six maybe it's got a
couple of lone pairs
it's got six valence electrons not four
okay
now but so if i had so when you look at
this you think
you know silicon looks like it wants
four uh bonds when you look at it and in
fact we know that
the crystalline silicon as we've talked
about gazunty is
is tetrahedral because of this right
it's tetrahedral remember
it's a two atom basis fcc lattice which
is
is diamond now but what if i just
look at it with oxygen i'm gonna come at
this without say well you know
i want to have four bonds uh one way to
do that
would be to add four oxygens so what if
i did this what if i did
uh silicon and oxygen and
i did plus four times the oxygen
well then you could see what what could
you do you could do this
okay and this and this
and this but now the okay the oxygens
how would they be left
they'd be left like this and you'll see
why i'm focusing on this
sio4 group in a minute
that's what i got now see okay if i go
back and i
put my lewis cap on silicon is very
happy it's it's obeying octet
and but but the oxygens aren't quite
there
so they need one more electron
one more electron i'm gonna make it a
little bolder because i've added it
right so i've added an electron to each
of those so if i had
sio4 and i added four
if i had sio4 and i added
four electrons to it might get a really
nice stable
lewis structure right oh and that's
called a silicate
that's a silicate group
sio4 and and i need those four electrons
as you can see just from looking at the
simple dot diagram i need those four
electrons to make it happy
okay by the way just speaking of naming
okay so let's see
silicate right silica
sio2 we've talked about so what we do is
when we have oxides
silicon oxide just in terms of naming
you know like if you have an oxide often
you add you kind of add an a right so
so like silicon went from s i
o two we call it silica
but you know so in al2o3
let's see al2o3 is also an oxide right
and so we called that this is something
we've already done
alumina all right
and so on except for sometimes and so
sometimes like for example
if you do if you do calcium oxide
uh well that's called lime
it's called lime calcium oxide
oh what about sodium well sodium if you
do sodium
you're gonna need it i'm assuming the
oxygen might break off and become too
mind you also
got to think about the charge again so
na2o
would be the one that works there right
and and this is sodium oxide ah but see
sodium oxide but sometimes
it's called soda because
and this is an extra step because soda
comes from calcium from let's see n a
two o from how do you make it you make
it from
na to co3
which is actually what is soda
calcium sodium carbonate
but because we make na2o
that oxide from something that we call
soda sometimes people just call in a20
soda
but it's not but sometimes you see that
so i just want to
kind of make you aware of some of these
names why am i writing it there we're
coming back to that
we're going to use those later that's
partly why i want them to be on the
board
and also tell you about the names so
na2o is sodium
oxide but it's made from sodium
carbonate which is soda
okay all right now okay now here's the
thing
that's an isolated molecule
look at what i'm passing around here oh
i wanted to tell you about the window
huh i almost forgot
in this class in this class we don't go
around saying
that windows are thicker on the bottom
than on the top because glass
flows like a liquid no
that is not true that is not true
that may be true down the street that is
not true here
we do the calculation glass is not a
liquid
not once it's cooled down into a solid
it's so it's a solid if you do the
calculation
and it's a centimeter thick a window
pane
for that piece of glass under
normal diffusion and temperature
conditions for that piece of glass at
the bottom to become
thicker by one nanometer would take 10
billion years
okay so so no it's not flowing
under its own weight in a window what
happened
what happened is people didn't know how
to make glass
uniformly way back when and so they came
out
on uniform non-uniform
what's easier to install it with the
heavier side up or the heavier side down
right it's easier to install it if it's
heavier on the bottom
glass doesn't flow okay all right i
wanted to get that done
early yeah now oh here we go this is
what
okay so this is quartz this is
crystalline silica this is this is
groups of
sio s-i-o-s sio2 not sio4
this was how we made a molecule happy
but watch what happens now when i go
from that picture
to sio2 so now
i've got these let's suppose i've got
these molecules
of and i'm just going to not draw it 3d
but i'm going to draw it 2d
and okay there's because then tight
there's all these charges there so now
these are
these are these molecules these silicate
groups
and they're kind of happy and they're on
their own but now look at what happens
here
see those two oxygen it what if instead
of
each of these being separate they came
together
right well you can see that you see if
they
shared the same oxygen here
if they shared the same oxygen here then
that oxygen is actually now
lewis happy without the extra charge
you see so so this oxygen
this bridge
oxygen doesn't need
that extra electron
to be happy what is to be happy mean
well we know what that means
and we're talking about lewis and
speaking in in those terms it means you
got your octet
right so now the bridge oxygen oh but
that
is what i'm passing around that is what
quartz is it's
all the oxygen's happy without needing
the extra charge
because they're all bridged
so that's what we've done we've made
silica
by thinking about it in terms of these
silicate groups
okay and just bridging them all together
and i can't draw it
but you you have it there and 3d models
are the easiest way to see it
and they all act as bridges between
silicate groups
okay so why am i why do i keep the
silicate group so
so a lot of times if you look up the
structure and this is the 3d structure
you can see every single oxygen
is a bridge every single oxygen is a
bridge
and it's nice to think about it in terms
of the silicate groups
why why did i start with that i started
with that because
these groups are very strong they stay
together
right and they kind of act as building
blocks for
the glass and for the quartz and you now
know those are two different things
quartz is is silicate groups ordered in
a crystal
glass is what we're gonna get to it's
when they're disordered
okay and and why is that well because
these oxygen you see all the
the silica the tetrahedron with the
silicon atom and those oxygens is pretty
robust
but the bond between the oxygens well
there's a whole lot of rotation that can
happen here
you see that that thing can rotate
around
so that's a good way to picture this
that's a good way to picture
quartz is these silicate groups that are
bonded together through these bridge
oxygens but they have a lot of
rotational and distortion
relative one and with respect to one
another
that is possible so
i take those silicate groups okay
here they are up top and i bring them
together and i make a perfect crystal
that is what's being passed around but
look because there's so much possibility
for
rotation and distortion maybe that
didn't happen
maybe as they as they start to form or
they find each other and they start
bridging
maybe they they didn't quite make it
i mean you can you can imagine these
things are kind of
these bulky groups coming together and
twisting around
you know you miss the mark it might be
hard to get back
so how how does one happen over the
other
right that's the crystal that's the not
crystal
the glass and it depends on a couple
things
and that's what i want to talk about
next it depends on the temperature
and the cooling depends on the
temperature and the cooling
so how does temperature come in so
temperature comes in
because temperature makes everything
vibrate
right it it gives these atoms in these
groups
kinetic energy okay so let's look at
that so if we were to plot for example
temperature versus the volume
per mole so this is you know for a given
number of these atoms
how many how much volume do they take
well you can imagine that that is
actually related
to how much energy they have right so
like
you know if i had like a crystal you
know maybe i'll start it here
and if i have a crystal you know and i
increase the temperature a little bit
maybe they're going to move more and and
as they move more
they need more room
right and this is just a simple you can
just think of like a simple
atom connected to another atom on a
spring
and more kinetic energy more temperature
it goes further
and now you're all thinking but wait a
second doesn't it go in
as far as it goes out why does it need
more volume
well that is because of what we have
already talked about which is this
energy curve
between between
two atoms or two silicate groups
this potential energy curve be that
plots the energy between those two
groups
and say the distance between them has
something very important about it has
something very important
this is this is a spring okay so i'm in
there
and and i'm at t equals zero here
that would be like t equals zero at the
absolute ground state the place where
everything is just in its minimum energy
but now i start
making things move right i put kinetic
energy into it
i increase the temperature what happens
the energy goes up but look it doesn't
go up
it goes like this the average i'm a
little bit higher in energy
right i'm a little bit higher in energy
so where i am is there
on average now i'm a little bit higher
in energy and so where i am is there
and now i'm a little bit higher and
where i am is there this
is what happens to the average that's
why
solids expand
it's because of the asymmetry in this
potential energy curve
which we have already talked about it's
because of the asymmetry
you see this is going out differently
than this goes up that's why you have
thermal expansion
right things are vibrating
but more often than not they're going to
be farther apart and so this happens
and so this happens so we've just
understood this from an atomic
so this would be like if i had a crystal
and i'm going to save three letters
and write excel that's so efficient
yeah and then i keep going and and this
by the way the slope of this
is called slope
is called the thermal expansion
coefficient thermal
expansion
that is the definition of the thermal
expansion coefficient
sometimes sometimes we use alpha
right that's the slope of this line it's
the volume per mole divided by
right over the temperature the change in
the volume of the change in temperature
just the thermal expansion coefficient
of the material
okay so i'm adding temperature and i'm
expanding and i'm expanding and then i
get to this point
i get to this point this point here
is where everything changes
everything changes that's the melting
point of the solid
that's the melting point now at the
melting point
as we know the whole thing goes through
a transition
it goes through a phase transition
and it becomes a liquid
right and and the thermal expansion of
the liquid is different than the solid
because those now you think about you
know they're
those are those molecules are not
rigidly bonded to each other anymore
they're more weakly bonded and they're
moving around with a lot of kinetic
energy
and so when they get more kinetic energy
they can expand even more
that's why those slopes are different
right
but as we know there's also a big volume
change
there's a sudden volume change right and
going from a solid
to a liquid there's a sudden volume
change
yeah and it would be the same thing if i
went back the other way
right yeah i'm cooling it down and
cooling it down and
and all of a sudden i get to the
solidification temperature
of the material and i become a crystal
i except when i don't
accept when i don't and when i don't
that's when i become a glass and that's
what we have to talk about now is how
do we go from this very simple picture
of being a glass adversary being a
liquid or being a solid
a crystalline solid how do we go from
that
to being a glass and
uh and and to explain this to start i
want to show you something really cool
that can happen
that actually wasn't an intentional pun
but it has to do with cooling
and it's really cool because sometimes
if you cool a liquid down it doesn't
solidify right there
and that's called super cooling so you
can actually cool a liquid down like
that
and have it stay a liquid
that would be called that's called super
cooling by the way
so this is called super cooling
by the way you can do that with water
and so i wanted to show you like one of
the coolest things you could do tonight
it's a friday night you're gonna have
guests over or
you'll be out at that same restaurant
that knows about you
because you asked them already all about
the candle
and the oxygen and you always come with
your periodic table and this time you
sit down and you say i don't want water
do you want sparkling or regular i want
super cooled
this is what you're gonna get this is
what they'll bring you they should if
it's a good restaurant this is what they
would bring you
um you know so here's a here's who is
super cool water being poured
okay this is what you should see in your
glass
now that is a
that is a liquid that is stable
for now below its melting point below
solidification point so what happens is
as soon as it hits the glass it's like
whoa wait a second
i i'm supposed to be a crystal and it
immediately solidifies
right so it immediately went like this
now by the way it's not that hard to
make super cool water if anybody's
interested
i'd be happy to tell you how to do it
you can't just put bottles in a freezer
that won't work but it's not that hard
to do
um now okay
back and forth melting point super
oh it's playing again and it starts
freezing
you can also take a bottle of super cold
water
and just go like this it's liquid inside
and just tap it and the whole thing
freezes instantly
it's really cool it's really cool
okay
now uh okay
now why am i talking about this
because
you can super cool and go down
you can go below that transition uh
point
and go and go down like i just did there
and become
a crystal right away now but you could
also
not you could also become
a solid so you could become a crystal
or you could also become a solid and i'm
going to need another
plot to do this and and you could become
a solid right where you were
you might not go down to the crystal
curve
but you might start a new curve and that
will be a glass
and so you know and so we're going to
draw this again and show you
a glass but this is what we need is this
framework
to understand when a glass forms so this
was our picture
crystalline crystalline glass amorphous
equals glass
when does it form now i think the best
i'll show you that one in a sec
i think the best way to think about it
is
let's let's draw the plot again and i
think the best way to think about it is
an analogy
that has been used before
um and let's see
and this is temperature this is volume
per mole by the way that could be
energy right enthalpy yeah because
because as the as the atoms aren't
packed in as well we know this right as
they're not packed in as well
they're also going to be you know higher
in energy
right the bonding won't be as strong
but i think that one of the best
analogies to think about is so i'm
coming in as a liquid
so i'm now a liquid
and here's my here's my melting point
for the crystal
for the crystal but i won't i went past
it
and i went past it and now instead of
i'm just going to draw this out here
there's the crystal
instead of
going down to become a crystal suddenly
or super cooling and then becoming a
crystal no
i super cool and then i just become a
solid
and then i just become a solid
okay now that this
is a glass
you know that it's a solid
it's got the same slope as the crystal
the thermal expansion of this thing
is the same as the crystal or very
similar
right so that's enough to tell you this
is this is a solid
right it should be a good indicator it
should have been a
nice straight line just for now
okay yeah but but um
but it didn't get those silicate blocks
didn't find the lattice they didn't find
the lattice they didn't
as you're here they've got all this
freedom
yeah they're a liquid silicate happy
maybe it's even higher temperature and
the silicons are even dissociated from
the oxygen but let's just assume
they're in these silicate groups and
they're floating around in a liquid
and i start cooling it i think one of
the best analogies that i've heard
is that of musical chairs how many of
you have played musical chairs
okay you've got to fix this tonight for
those of you who didn't raise your hand
that's going on the menu tonight
because it's a really fun game
with supercooled water of course
you line up some chairs and you get
around in a group
and you walk around it as the music
plays
and then the music stops and everybody
has to find a chair
but there's a chair missing so you got
to go fast
or you might not get to a chair
okay well you see the the silicates
let's put it below here the silicates
are you
you are the silicates people
equal silicate
and the chair
equal lattice
sights
and now you can really feel it you can
really feel it because the speed
around the chairs how fast are you
moving
right so the speed
well if it's if it's uh speed around
the chair okay if that's fast
then um then it's you know high mobility
so so let's see speed around chair let's
do this
high mobility
maybe you'd find you know find
lattice sights easier
or faster at least but see
if you have a high one over mobility
by the way that's also viscosity if you
have a high one over mobility
so if you have a high viscosity
viscosity
high one over mobility high viscosity
then it's slow and that's how
you have a higher chance of forming
glass so i'm going to talk about
why right what would make a glass form
if you're just walking around slowly
like this
everyone else is running but maybe
you're all walking slowly and now the
music stops and i'm like
you know i'll take my time it's going to
be hard to get to the open lattice
site right i might just get stuck
okay so what else well okay so how about
the arrangement
so the chair arrangement
that has to do with the crystal
complexity
and you can imagine that if the chairs
are arranged in a straight line and
you're going around the chairs and it's
kind of an easy
loop right now i don't have to
concentrate too much on where i'm going
and it's kind of there's nothing really
blocking me i hope
but what if those chairs were arranged
in a really complicated way
right so how hard is it to get around
these chairs how is it is to find them
how complex is the lattice and you can
imagine
that it is higher so uh
let's see um more i'll just draw an
arrow higher
would lead to glass okay so it fits
higher complexity of the lattice
it might be harder to find the lattice
sights in this musical chairs
okay one more and i'll put it here so
that it's close by
because i got no more room on that board
the third one is how fast you stop the
music so this would be like one
two and then three
how fast we stop music
okay so you can imagine if i you know
i if i slowly we're playing musical
chairs
and i am walking around and i i slowly
fade the music
right well then you got lots of time you
got lots of time but what if i just
stop it everybody's scrambling
right so how fast you stop the music is
the cooling rate
it's how quickly you cool this material
it's how fast you stop the music and you
can imagine
that if it's faster faster
you are more likely to form a glass
you're more likely to form a glass and
so we go back to our picture
well maybe i'll draw one over here
because i need more room
and i don't want to block what's there
we go back to our picture and here it is
drawn out for you
you see that is okay there's the liquid
line
coming in volume okay enthalpy
we'll keep thinking about is volume the
liquid line comes in
you're cooling it down there's the
thermal expansion it's reducing reducing
and now i get to the melting temperature
and i become a crystal
that's if it can become a crystal but
all of these factors now
matter
the melting point of the crystal is
always
the same number it's always the same
number the melting point
where the crystal melts and because the
crystal is always the same
right where that melts is always the
same temperature
but notice now what have i done i've
supercooled the
liquid down and on a
i've got a glass that looks like this
these are glasses
and on b i've got a glass that looks
like that those are different
and they have different solidification
temperatures
and what do we call it we have a special
name for it too
we have a special name for it because
it's not crystallizing right so if this
is the volume per mole
and this is the temperature it's not
crystallizing no what is it doing so
that would be the melting point
it is turning into
a glass and so we call this the glass
transition temperature
it's a glass transition what that means
is
it is still becoming because in tight
a solid but it's an amorphous solid
it's not a crystal why did it become an
amorphous solid well maybe i cooled it
really
fast or maybe it's a really complex
structure
right or maybe the viscosity of the
material is very high and it just
as i'm cooling it down it just couldn't
find the crystal lattice which is all
the way down here
and you can see from this that you know
imagine i take the extreme limit
and i got my liquid of my silicate
groups
and right as i get below here i'm like
you're all frozen
i'd literally i'd make a glass right
here
right up there right
so i can make glasses that are different
from each other
and you can see that the volume
per mole is increasing as i go up and
you can understand that
because look i took a glass i didn't let
i took a liquid here
this is the liquid i didn't let any of
it find crystal sites
it's a liquid but i said ha you're
frozen
and it became frozen and stuck at a high
volume
per mole because it's totally random and
amorphous
it's coming right from all those all
those random liquid degrees of
freedom are just frozen in yeah but now
i cool it
i cool it slower maybe that's what
happened here right
and i give it more time and i give it
more time to find
some of those lattice sites and it finds
some lattice lights but then
it it it became a glass at this
temperature the glass transition
temperature
and everything else is frozen in
right so so if i label this so let's
label it the same as there
if i label a as this one
and b is this one and this is the
crystal
nope that's the crystal would have to go
all the way up to here
there we go right
so if that's if that's a that's glass
and that's class b
then which one did i cool faster
well i had to cool this one slower if if
all i changed between them is cooling
rate
then then this one is cooled faster
cool so let me write it here a
cooled slower
than b
right because i get and that's that's
this one here how fast did you stop the
music
right it's the cooling rate okay
so this plot this volume versus
temperature
really allows us to understand how
glass forms or at least we can plot
you know what what happened and then try
to understand it
and if it did get all the way to the
crystal then maybe it means that
it's not very viscous as a liquid it
doesn't have a complex lattice site
and maybe it didn't even matter how
quickly oh metals
that's why it's hard to make glasses out
of metals
because metals have an easy time finding
their lattice sites metals
as liquids typically aren't very viscous
and so even if you cool it you know kind
of faster
it's got time the musical chairs of
metals is easy
it's an easy game that's why
the silicates never play musical chairs
with metals
yeah but but i can still do it and the
way you make a glass out of a metal the
way you make a metallic glass which is a
really cool material
is you you freeze it really quickly
you lower the temperature as quickly as
you can
really really fast and you freeze in the
disorder and you make a metallic glass
okay and so those are the two curves i
just talked about there
that's the glass curve this would be the
crystal curve
okay two different cooling rates
on here okay now
here's a picture of float glass this is
the kind of glass you know
we're going to move from understanding
what glass
is an understanding in terms of you know
this temperature versus volume plot
and amorphous solids and and we're going
to move towards understanding how to
modify it how to control
it because we do a lot of that here's an
example of a factor
i like this this is float glass so this
is like when you buy you know your
windows
or you know a lot of a lot of times when
you need a very clear
beautiful piece of glass you go up to
very high temperatures
right so you're taking those silicates
you make them into a liquid here he is
measuring the temperature i don't know
what he's doing actually
whatever oh and uh this isn't showing up
very well
and there's no volume so double okay
there it is right so there's the liquid
glass
why is it called float class the process
is monitored continuously by technicians
to ensure quality
but because it floats on top
of another liquid layer that's how you
get the glass
to control the stress on the glass and
ensure uniformity and there it is coming
out
there's a nice wide piece of glass
coming out and what he says
at the end of this there it is coming
out they do they can do kilometers and
kilometers per day
of this float glass you float it over
molten tin
the tin acts like this really nice
smooth
surface that you put the glass on on top
of so one liquid on top of another
makes a very nice smooth interface and
what he talks about which is what i
wanted to capture is how important
that cooling is so the line has to go
in a very particular way after it comes
out as you cool it
and because it's all about the cooling
right as you come all the way back down
to here room temperature right or as i
as i maybe as i went through this
transition
what's happening inside am i creating a
lot of stress
we just learned about stress am i
creating a lot of stress right or is it
is it going to cool in a nice way
are there going to be cracks that form
so that
is one of the most important processing
parameters
what we'll learn next week is that is
that chemistry is also a really
important processing power
and that's why you have such good phone
screens actually
you don't really because they always
break but they would break even more if
it weren't for chemistry
okay but but certainly cooling speed is
a really important one so so let's go to
the camera so
okay now how okay if you look at glass
everybody said that it's it's got order
or no order crystalline
amorphous crystalline amorphous how do
you tell which one you have
who can tell me you
just learned about it
what do you do to see if something is a
crystal and which crystal it is
you shine x-rays on it you go to your
x-ray source and you just shine it on
and you
measure where it bounces off but see now
so if you did that so if you look in the
circle they look the same
they look the same that's crystalline
that's quartz
this is glass quartz glass crystalline
amorphous
right but if you go to the long range
order there isn't any so if i shine
x-rays
these are two different types of solids
think about it like bccfcc but they're
not
they're more complicated of of uh of
quartz
and or of silicates this is what glass
would look like
look at that yeah but so there's still
like a little bit of a peak there but
not really right
this is from the short range order but
here's the most
here's the important part which is why
you can still
even though it's not that everything is
where you think it is
right because in a crystal you know
everything's bcc
or fcc every lattice is the same you
know you can count on it for 10 to the
20 second
repetitions here you can't you can still
control the properties
you can still control the properties so
the properties can be highly engineered
and here's an example so um
this is these are different types of
glass this is a glass cup
and this is a glass bottle and and you
might think it's just glass
no it's not just glass it's
very complicated mixtures of silica
with other things notice it's got soda
this is like i said this is not soda but
it comes from soda so it's called soda
sodium oxide
na2o lime cao
magnesia alumina
all the glass you know unless you pay a
whole lot of money for something made of
quartz
almost all the glass you buy has this
kind of stuff in it
in fact 90 of all glass is is called
soda glass
because it's got that's this one here
that's this cup because it's got
sodium oxide in it and the question is
why
why do we put these things in glass why
did we used to put lead in glass
in fact the history is is uh is pretty
good goes back thousands of years
and i found this if you go to ancient
rome they made glass
and and you can look at what they made
glass out of they had a little bit less
silica
but they mixed all sorts of things in
they did not have
uh 3091 back then so they didn't really
know
why this was doing something useful but
it was
right now we mix all these oxides
remember i wrote some of them up here
lime soda we mix those in and we mix all
sorts of other things in
but now we know why and and the reason
why
is all about the chemistry and it all
goes back
to this picture right here it all goes
back
to exactly this lewis structure that i
started with which is not on the
ah stop it no
it's not here maybe it's here
yes that made me happy
this all goes back to the chemistry
if i deliver if i deliver
into this system
something that gives me charged oxygens
something that provides a little bit of
o minus or
two minus then i could cut this bond
back
i can cut this all the way back to the
original silicate
sort of i could if i had an oxygen with
charge on it
i could go from here back to where i
started
right there at least for that bond right
and so what every single one of these
things has in common
is that it can provide into the system
a charged oxygen a charged oxygen atom
if this dissociates
it gives me ca2 plus and o2 minus if
this dissociates it gives me two na
pluses and an o2 minus
oh a pattern is forming here o two minus
o two minus o two minus
all the way down so these modifiers
these things
that we use to engineer glass they give
me
the o2 minus and and and that
is the the the knife that i use to cut
this this glass apart and and modify its
properties
and it's where we're going to pick up on
wednesday but because it's a friday i
want to throw t-shirts out
we'll do more next week have a really
good holiday weekend
you